everybody peaceful if I got away Thanks
huh you're right good to see you man
let's go so we're deep in zombie-killing
territory we're in a hotel where we're
just murdering zombies right in the left
all right here we go all right yeah you
are you got a little machine gun there
I'm not exactly sure we're supposed to
go we're just looking at all the
depressing people are just hanging out
in these hotels you played this game
before but I have yeah perfect
now what's your are you playing any
games these days or do you not really
calm swings destiny right now oh dude
what do you think
it's pretty fun um yeah I like it I like
I know I don't usually play shooters
this is actually one of the few shooters
that I play Oh what do you normally play
rpgs yeah that's awesome wait hold on
let me get back with everybody else now
I've come up with I think my catchphrase
for when I kill people is gonna be it's
Britney [ __ ] I screaming it do you have
a catchphrase or do you want to make one
up all right so here are the controls
you remember melee is left shooting is
right reload picking stuff up action
switching weapons and jump which ones
picking stuff up is X yeah there you go
get it you matter
oh wait I think you might are you having
oh yeah I think you already rockin news
okay Cousy style awesome oh you're on
the show tonight yeah I am very exciting
very exciting I know man I think Todd
and I were over here there we go here
are you a big fan of Halloween I am I
love Hal oh I love it
that's my favorite also are you you know
did you dress up um you know what not so
much dress up oh gee hurry up I took the
pain pills
let's say yeah you're dressing up
normally I guess you don't really need
it I think the last year Jesus oh yeah
oh man Ricky yes I don't think that's
gonna catch on as a good Petra I had to
stop playing for a minute but I was at
level I think I made level 14 whoo there
we go and then I had to stop for a bit
and what did you know what's your guy
are you robot yeah I play a woman she's
what's that really weird race thing how
do you woken yeah yeah and hell yeah
some seafoam green hair that's awesome I
know I think I'm playing it's like a
robot or an EXO a woman exit oh yeah
they're very cool which is kind of great
I gotta say dusty I'm like a destiny
it's weird when I see other real people
I'm not like a fan of like running into
real people me neither I don't like in
her I don't I don't like interactive
that's why I'm playing video games you
know it's like I don't enjoy the
multiplayer addict I guess the boys from
playing destiny is you don't have to
talk to anybody
yeah that's the pen at least yet you can
just be like just kill a bunch of people
together and go on your merry way mm-hmm
I'm not sure wait let's try running we
came from the left we came from over
there I'm getting healed thanks rychelle
shells putting your sweet yeah nice yeah
chillin Legend of Zelda I can't crawl
under here have you played um have you
played that game Hyrule warriors I
haven't yet oh man it's great I guess
I've never played dynasty warriors based
on played that oh here we go we got
[Music]
yeah yeah that's not a that's not a good
idea and maybe we should get back up on
the highway that might be a good idea
[Laughter]
[Music]
in town just spinner public death the
death blossom yeah yeah just one man
death blossom man we're trapped in this
terrible hotel you know what maybe let's
go this way
now what what song you playing tonight
on the show no shoes no shirt no shoes
wise choice
yeah very ironic yeah and yeah I really
I love the new album it's like it feels
like it's got a little Britpop in it
which is for sure which is a big fan of
that when I was going to art school and
before that's me yeah love awesome very
yeah and are you going are you on tour
now are you go into her
I am yeah I just started a tour that's
it's just some some u.s. major cities
and then after that we're gonna go to
the UK oh that's fun
yeah I loved playing there that's good
do you have favorite places you like
playing or the rock I love playing UK in
London is is probably my favorite yeah I
do love a lot of places like playing
Japan oh my god that's gotta be awesome
yeah America's cool
what's the now what's one thing if you
had that would surprise your fans know
about you what oh you pretty much name
I'm not pretty on them but I'm very
vocal about like the weird yeah it's
awesome
Oh waits for you hey you know what you
wrote I've read it yet but the impelling
Academy which is great and you're gonna
write for Marvel today comes out that's
awesome man you love edge of
spider-verse and that's Miles Morales
right no mine is a character named penny
Parker that up I made up just for oh my
god yeah that's awesome
did you know how'd that work did you get
to pitch them a story or did they come
to you um the editor Nick Lowe came to
me and he'd been a fan of my work and
it's awesome he was like no man I'm
giving this hotel by the way a terrible
yelp review there's zero slob yes oh
there we go
yeah no no I'm almost fighting it I'm in
the process of planning it oh there we
go
yeah there we go switch into the sword
switch into the sword oh my god here
they come
oh man get over there just yeah
[Music]
I did I used to be so addicted to it
stop
I was very addicted to it I'm dead
[Music]
awesome I know I feel like I can't get
into you whenever quests like first came
out I was like nope like I believe the
original EverQuest oh yeah yeah I'm that
into it oh my god I could never I'm Dean
D so when that came out oh yeah I spent
I you know what I've never actually
played true dungeon and Dragons I used
to play this game rifts remember I
remember red yeah yeah I played I played
rifts yeah I was I was deep into rifts
but I never actually did the traditional
D&D
yeah it's great do you still play or no
um you know I play with a group of
friends we haven't played an event but
we're gonna start a game up again in
December when I come back home all right
oh that's cool okay awesome I'm pretty
pumped about that you know let's get
back up on the highway I think that's
how does that where we gonna go I think
I can see I don't I don't think that
this is doing much for us just can't get
past this people are calling you out
they're going in circles yeah yeah we
don't know we're going yeah does anybody
know where we should go see I feel like
we want to get going right Yeah right
how does right here we go now we're
gonna bet but I think we need to
backtrack to go forward if I'm not
mistaken no wait like you we can't go
over that wailing upper floor Hotel
upper apartment
Oh upper apartments in the hood all
right all right this is great like I
wish I could play over the chat room all
the time it's like this normally mean
this would be like in my apartment like
three hours of just like where am I
going
thanks guys good more questions for sure
man upper floors
oh yeah oh yeah there we go we're both
wearing a blue suit tonight it's gonna
private oh hey I found up a lot of
zombies over here you have any favorite
zombie flicks dad oh the original or
they leaving
I love the remake yeah via original
classic I uh what I just see that was
awesome I just saw a great upper
apartments they say well maybe we need
to like get on the roof and then jump
off or something
reload is
um it actually is no-shows oh sweet that
and get the gang together I pink no
show's over single because it was my
favorite oh here we go
This Is It this is feeling something I
feel like back over here right yeah yeah
and then maybe out
not this way out through the window
maybe here we go yeah I don't think
we've been over here right you know this
will tell us a lot of here's one
criticism that a lot of - oh gee yep oh
oh here we go here tonight don't fall in
this acid because it will kill you like
it's killing me oh man oh wait oh thank
you oh god oh god
nice that's teamwork right there oh man
I haven't felt cocky enough to say my
catchphrase lately that's a problem the
catchphrase is if you're getting
murdered you kind of feel really stupid
yeah it's hard to be like it's Britney
[ __ ] and just like getting them to run
zombies
here we go at a camp replaced by in
London there we go
that's sure what time is it in London
right now hey 30 nice prime video game
watching tonight well I got something
the laser sight now we're talking
it's laser sight he's gonna I'm just
honestly I'm just glad to be out of that
hotel that was dad definitely that's
getting very look off here they come
very low stars I promise a veces filthy
looks like the meets hadn't been that a
long time and blood all over the walls
not good no I think I'm just really bad
let's just go this way the way the
zombies can we go this way
I'd be up the hill meant to the here
this way I think
all right here I think our Mike's
Marmite
[Music]
wow this is this river is full of zombie
you know I don't feel I don't feel good
about walking in this water doesn't look
that good yeah definitely get some kind
of apocalypse I you know I don't want to
get some weird foot fungus you know it's
just really embarrassing if I have to
take out my shoes and socks you know I
get up cool party or something I'm
thinking about life after this yeah yeah
yeah you know you got it you gotta be
gone guessing there be a lot of houses
open I'm just gonna take you know
because everyone will yeah yeah yeah
don't pad and maybe get two
refrigerators dragging another fridge
from another another place you know
isn't it set up that's my dream some
people want like I could have one with
all fudgesicles and creamsicles
and then one with just like normal food
I would love
[Music]
that is kind of surprising actually
oh all right
you know how to love it
I'm a little uh well I don't know what
The Creature from the Black Lagoon it's
really got its full now day of the Sun
Wow I'm getting just absolutely
destroyed who is that guy oh it's got
great ABS though great abs on that
monster great abs oh yeah you're still
killing all right do me Mel do you have
any last questions for John there's a
favorite game at the moment with one
question
maybe maybe besides destiny besides I'm
playing that studio ghibli game studio
ghibli what's that I made it I forget
the title quick looks like something
with a white witch or something but we
made it we beat the level nice huh
yeah there in spirit xx
nice job well done
awesome well cool thanks for playing and
thanks everybody for watching say
goodbye to Gerard downstairs
alright make sure to watch no shows
tonight on Conan alright guys see you
later thanks why thank you
you